gerade wurde bekannt dass die regierung
der usa jahrelang mit millionenaufwand
ufo forschung betrieben hat ist es also
gar nicht so abwegig nach ufos zu
forschen
und genau da setzt das projekt
rostockern hier kann jeder mitmachen und
sich als augenzeuge nicht seriöser
objekte am himmel eintragen die kabel
zeigt an wann und wo welche objekte
gesichtet worden sind die viele
unbekannte flugobjekte allein im jahr
2017 registriert worden sind und wo
offensichtlich die in den hotspots
dieser welt liegen jetzt den klicks um
science-fiction herzlich willkommen die
interaktive karte funktioniert ganz
einfach wann und wo wurde das unbekannte
flugobjekt gesichtet und wie sah es
genau aus diese informationen kann jede
augenzeuge auf der website ufo stalker
eingeben wenn möglich dann sogar mit
einem beweisfoto dann wird eine
fallnummer erstellt und der sichtung
sword sowie die kommentare des
jeweiligen augenzeugen werden ihnen die
datenbank eingespeist und es werden
tatsächlich daten aus der ganzen welt
aufgenommen
doch user können nicht nur ihre eigenen
ufo-sichtungen eingeben sondern sich
auch anschauen ob und wann außerirdische
in ihrer nähe entdeckt worden sind die
ufo symbole der interaktiven karte
müssen dafür ganz einfach angeklickt
werden und schon werden die mehr oder
weniger detaillierten berichte angezeigt
da heißt es dann zum beispiel in einem
bericht vom 18
märz 2017 aus würselen also deutschland
nrw
das objekt war schnell flog im zickzack
kurs und leuchtete grünen erst vor
kurzem mitte dezember wurde ein
seltsames objekt in der iranischen stadt
sowie sarah gemeldet in dem bericht
heißt es
ich habe es gegen mitternacht vom
grundstück meiner oma beobachtete sah
aus wie eine untertasse und machte keine
geräusche
es leuchtete blau und es schien so als
würde es nicht beobachten erstaunlich
bisher sind insgesamt rund 84.000
sichtungen gemeldet wurden allein im
jahr 2017 waren es rund 5500 und damit
gab es einen anstieg zum vorjahr um etwa
acht prozent sind aliens also
tatsächlich auf dem vormarsch oder
beteiligen sich einfach nur sehr viel
mehr leute mysteriöse objekte am himmel
gesehen zu haben
ohne frage hat damit sicher auch das in
kann es zu tun denn viel arbeit ist es
wahrscheinlich nicht dort mal schnell
angaben zum mysteriösen objekten am
himmel zu machen es dauert etwa 10 bis
15 minuten und geht auch anonym
man kann die sichtung aber auch nach
beliebigen kriterien filtern zum
beispiel nach region monatag oder ja
dabei scheinen die meisten berichte im
sommer ein so gehen vor allem im juli
scheinen sich besonders oft seltsame
phänomene am himmel abzuspielen
das objekt basiert auf dem
elektronischen fall bearbeitungsprogramm
der ufa organisation nur von case
management system wovon steht für
network und seinen sitz ist in den usa
eines der hauptziele die öffentlichkeit
über das ufo phänomen und die möglichen
auswirkungen auf die gesellschaft zu
informieren wenn eine sicherung
eingegeben wird schauen sich danach nur
von freiwillige foto analysten das
beigefügte bildmaterial an so heißt es
auf der website
sie verwenden eine reihe von
verschiedenen techniken um die
authentizität des fotos oder videos zu
identifizieren und zu versuchen eine
meinung darüber abzugeben ob es sich um
eine echte oder um eine fälschung
handeln und um den ursprung des objekts
auf dem foto allerdings das projekt ist
alles andere als wissenschaftlich
schließlich gibt es keine
ausschlusskriterien nach denen die
meldungen aus gesehen werden jeder
wirklich jeder kann berichte eintragen
und so ist es natürlich klar dass es
sich wenn überhaupt bestimmt nicht bei
allen meldungen um außerirdische handeln
würde
selbst wenn tatsächlich echte
ufo-sichtungen dabei werden denn
schließlich gibt es viele andere
erklärungen für seltsame erscheinungen
oder lichter am himmel das wetter meteo
schauer oder beispielsweise flugzeug
test oder drohen inzwischen als das kann
dahinter stecken trotzdem visualisiert
die karte natürlich super wann und wo
angeblich mysteriöse objekte am himmel
zu sehen waren spannend dabei oft werden
ja karge wüsten gegen den mit alien
hotspots assoziiert doch die karte ufos
tor gezeigt dass sich die berichte dort
eher auf großstädte und dicht besiedelte
ballungszentren konzentrieren große
hotspots sind tatsächlich new york und
die umliegenden metropolen genauso wie
kalifornien dass so viele ufos in den
usa beobachtet werden das liegt sicher
auch daran dass das projekt amerikanisch
ist doch wo stalker ist nicht die
einzige bank die sich auf die sichtung
von außerirdischen spezialisiert hat es
gibt auch deutsche web
zu diesem thema die ufo datenbank die
gilt nach eigenen angaben im
deutschsprachigen raum als zentrales
archiv für dokumentationen von
gemeldeten ufo sichtungen in
elektronischer form ihr selbsterklärtes
ziel ist es allen ufo interessenten eine
möglichst große auswahl an sichtungs
berichten zur selbst recherche zur
verfügung zu stellen die ufo datenbank
verweist im übrigen auch die grundsätze
jeglicher wissenschaftlicher praxis in
der erforschung des ufo phänomens auf
der webseite heißt es unter anderem die
erforschung des ufo phänomens geschieht
in form wissenschaftlich kritische
arbeit offenheit für unterschiedliche
sichtweisen sowie die bereitschaft die
eigenen ergebnisse zu hinterfragen mit
anderen selbst kritisch zu diskutieren
und unliebsame erkenntnisse zu
akzeptieren gehören zur
grundvoraussetzung aller forscher neben
dem sichtungs datum und derzeit liefert
die website auch gleich eine beurteilung
sowie wenn möglich eine identifikation
mit so beispielsweise mit einer sichtung
vom 19 08 und 2017 in ostfildern und
zwar als ein ufo also ein
identifizierbares fliegendes objekt in
diesem fall waren es vögel ja wir haben
hier ja so oft über künstliche
intelligenz ki bericht den ich bin mal
gespannt wenn eine solche software wie
zum beispiel google brain die daten
durchforstet vielleicht kristallisieren
sich dann wirklich echte sichtungen von
raumschiffen heraus mal schauen wenn ihr
kein video zu diesem thema und auch zu
allen anderen dem verpassen wollt dann
drückt mir hier ein abo aufsaugen
vergessen nicht den
auf die glocke nur dann werdet ihr auch
immer über neue videos informiert hier
geht es weiter mit dafür draufklicken
außerirdische revolution bei der suche
da geht es auch um den einsatz von ki
bei der suche nach außerirdischen
ansonsten bis dann bleibt dran